Andrew really appreciate the time I
guess let's just start with your story
for the people that didn't get a chance
to read it yet on how profound the
difference really is between the NBA and
the NFL yeah good morning Ross always
good to be with you the NFL and NBA we
all got these free agent deals we do it
in March every year mid March for the
NFL and we do it in July fourth week
every year for the NBA and the numbers
on the contract values overall are
relatively equal you know we'll hear
about NFL deals that are 80 million
dollars 90 120 million the same way
we'll hear about NBA but here's the key
difference in the NBA
100 million equals 100 million they're
guaranteed contracts they have full
security the shift of risk goes to the
team not the player the team has all the
risk on these deals in the NFL even for
the best of the best this happened with
Derek Carr this week it's really two
years I mean which is the lowest risk
for the team that the guys going to play
well right away this year next year and
then after that we'll see even for the
best free agents they get the first year
guaranteed probably there's a trigger
for a second year guarantee in March and
then kind of after that it's the team's
option and that's the major difference I
don't think it's overall money I think
it's security and I think I when I hear
arguments well NFL contracts are
guaranteed because of the injury risk
well I'm like that's a great argument
for the owners but what about the
players you could argue they need it
more because of the injury risk so
that's the primary difference Ross so
okay so then why would be my question
why is the NBA so much better than the
NFL in that regard in your opinion I
think the two agents and there's a
collective agent for the players and
there's an individual agent for the
players NBPA NFLPA those are the unions
so on the Union side what can they do
they can get a higher guaranteed money
guarantee overall and we talked about
caps
but to me the issue is not really caps
because both these leagues had caps its
minimum spending by teams by the league
I just don't think it's high enough in
the NFL the Union can work on that but
even greater need is the individual
agents especially for the Stars to
really hold the feet to the fire of the
teams to say we really need this
guaranteed beyond two years yeah I mean
what is they what other Raiders can I
say to Derek Carr and his agents when
they say you're really worried about
cutting them at age 30 why don't you
just guarantee it and those are the kind
of things you got to break the seal and
it has to start with the stars like a
car like a look like a Rodgers like a
Cam Newton and then you'll have a
trickle down after that that's what it's
going to take Ross speaking of breaking
the seal by the way I am going to wait
as long as possible tonight after I
start having some daddy sodas before I I
break the seal Andrew appreciate any
time you can come on and join me here
talking to Andrew Brandt the vice
president of player finance for the
Green Bay Packers for a very very long
time what about just the the total money
and you're like what about I know
there's less players in the NBA and I
know that there's a lot more games but
where's the NBA revenue at compared to
the NFL and how much bigger of a slice
to the NBA players get of the total
revenue than the NFL guys do and I do
hear the argument all the time when I
tweet about the difference in these
contracts but hey the NBA has got so
many fewer players obviously I know that
you know that everyone listening knows
that about a quarter of the roster so 15
players versus 60 when you kind of
practice squad injured players etc for
the NFL but look at it this way the cap
last year and the NBA was 94 million for
15 players so you're talking whatever
that is 66 points something million
average if you just slice it down that
way for the NFL you're talking 155
million for 60s sometimes 70 players
so that slice allocation is about two
million per player a little over two so
we're talking about three times the
difference allocation for NBA players
that just that doesn't seem right when
the revenues I don't know the most
recent NBA number Ross but you know the
NFL is going up about a billion dollars
a year in total revenues it dwarfs other
leagues so we're going to be about
fourteen billion by the end of next year
in terms of total revenue so revenue
should matter and it just doesn't seem
like they're mattering in this case so
what about when you look at the model
right now for the two sports I think
that's what we're getting to we're
getting to the heart of right model
between the NBA and the NFL the NBA is
generating it seems like Andrew a lot
more buzz in the offseason that maybe
even the NFL specifically free agency
okay I think the NFL Draft still gets
more than the NBA Draft but specifically
free agency there's just a lot more buzz
in the NBA because there can be these
big trades like the Chris Paul trade
doesn't seem to happen very often the
NFL and you've got some marquee players
that are free agent and likely to switch
teams which again rarely happens in the
NFL but the flip side I guess andrew is
you had a bunch of teams in the NBA that
really have no shot because they don't
have you know two or three star players
like you need which what do you think
has the better model you know I think it
depends on how you feel about management
and players there is more liberties
there's more power in the NBA player
base than the NFL player base and one
reason you've got to think if not for
obvious reasons the leadership of the
NBA Players Association the president is
a guy you've we've obviously been
talking about the past couple days Chris
Paul and the vice president is a guy
named LeBron James I think that matters
I really do I just think they bring a
gravitas to the bargaining table with
owners sitting across from them nothing
against the player leaders for the NFLPA
I just think if you had pick a name
Russell Wilson Cam Newton
Aaron Rodgers Tom Brady sitting in
across I think it would come out at the
end of the deal that there'd be a little
more given I just think that brings it
the other part of it is that the NBA
really has because of these future
guarantees the trading is interesting
because it's about expiring contracts
it's about picking up players that will
be off your roster like Brook Lopez
traded Lakers the headline was well
they'll use his cap room in 18 to get a
superstar and that's much more
interesting than sort of the NFL where
there are no future guarantees except
for a loan exception like a Brock
Osweiler trade you just don't even need
those trades because teams just dump
players because their contracts aren't
guaranteed so there's just a lot more
interesting business options when you
have players having the power that they
do and can dramatically alter fortunes
of teams last question I have for you in
Jersey and it's something that you and I
talked about it might even earlier this
week on on my podcast but the next thing
that's coming up that's going to be big
after NBA free agency after about the
next week or so it's going to be the
franchise tag deadline in the NFL and
it's really primarily going to be Kirk
Cousins that's more interesting than
lady on bail or Tremaine Johnson
whatever I'm just curious to get your
thoughts on what you think is going to
happen with Kirk Cousins because every
report you hear everybody out there says
it's highly highly unlikely that they
get a deal done yeah and I and I believe
you as well have a little bit of counter
intuitive feeling about Kirk Cousins I
hear about all this leverage and if they
get this franchise tag next year and
35-minute whatever I just think deadline
spur action it's going to come down to a
situation next the middle of July where
Kirk Cousins has a choice he can play
for 24 million nothing wrong with that
for one year or he can accept the
Redskins deal which is probably not
probably definitely not going to be in
line with some of these per
directions and and taking doing town a
thirty five million dollar franchise
next year it's going to be picking
numbers I don't know fifty to fifty five
million guaranteed and you can do all
the calculations you want that that's
not enough he's got so much leverage but
at the end of the day is he going to
take twenty four million guaranteed or
is it going to take fifty something
million guaranteed and I think that's
what it comes down to and I think at the
end of the day he'll do a deal and to
argue about the theories of future tags
is kind of irrelevant now maybe he'll
have a lot of leverage next year but
that's next year so I just think it
comes down to do you want to do a deal I
think Kirk Cousins ultimately despite
all the noise about being unhappy
earlier this offseason does want to do a
deal and I think one gets done July 15th
or 16th the deadlines of 17th and you
really appreciate the time always did
the talk with you on any outlet I can I
can get you on the horn thanks so much
you got it Ross enjoyed it the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience